>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> And so that being said,
I'd like to welcome you.
My name is Alison Starling,
I work at ABC 7 and anchor
of Good Morning Washington,
nice and early.
I'm the ABC affiliate here in DC.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much.
So happy to be back out here
for the National Book
Festival once again this year,
and it's only fitting
in this historical occasion near the
Washington monument near the capital
that we're celebrating
here the inspirational
and motivational stories
of immigrants who have come
to our country and sacrificed
so much to be Americans.
But first, you should know that
for our presentation today,
we have sort of a special set up.
You are a special guest today
and that's because of instead
of the typical forum
when the author comes up
and gives their presentation
and simply takes questions
from the audience, instead, today,
our author somehow convinced a world
famous journalist to come with him
and actually do the
interviews for him.
We don't know how he
managed to do that.
We'll have to find out.
I am happy to introduce two people
here for you today, the author
and the interviewer, and
they happen to be a couple.
First we have Steve Roberts
who has been a journalist
for more than 40 years.
He was a journalist with the
New York Times and with US News.
He is of course a well-known
commentator, a lecturer,
a professor and an author.
This is his second time at
the National Book Festival.
He was here as well in
2005 for his memoir,
his childhood memoir
called My Father's House.
Secondly, you will be
seeing the interviewer,
and that is his wife, Cokie Roberts.
As you know, Cokie is an Emmy--
[ Applause ]
>> Yes, applause for Cokie.
She is an Emmy award winning
journalist and commentator as well.
She is with the National
Public Radio and ABC news.
She and her husband write a popular
nationally syndicated newspaper
column together as well.
They have two children,
they have six grandchildren,
at least one of which I
know is here today, Regan.
And they also in 2000,
Steve and Cokie published,
From This Day Forward, which
was an account of their marriage
and other marriages
in American history.
And you know what, it's been 7
weeks at the Times bestseller list.
It's a book that I personally
enjoyed very much and in it,
this is one of my favorite quotes.
They say marriage has enlarged
our lives, not encircle them.
It has opened new doors,
not closed them.
We are better people together
than we are separately.
Today, they are here to
talk about Steve's new book
about the immigration experience and
the search for the American dream.
That book is called From
Every End of this Earth.
I hope you will help me to
welcome Steve and Cokie Roberts.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much.
We're so thrilled of you to come.
Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Now I think someone is supposed
to come whisk this lecture in array.
Otherwise-- [laughter] here we go.
Withstand it, okay, thank
you, thank you very much.
What a great, what a great day.
I mean Dr. Jim Billington
is with us right here,
The Librarian of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> And well, and Jim and Laura
Bush together saw a vision of a day
like this 10 years ago of
bringing hundreds of thousand--
hundreds of thousands of people on a
hot day to the National Hall to talk
about books, buy books, and listen
to authors talk about books,
and what a great thing it is.
So, my job here today is
basically to say to Steve,
so tell me the one about.
[Laughter] But first, I
know that you like to talk
about why you wrote this
book in the first place.
>> That's true and thank you.
What did you say your name was?
[Laughter] We just had
our 44th anniversary
and I'm still getting used to it.
[ Applause ]
>> Although you know the best line
about Steve's best line really
about marriage is not
in the book but it is
that you can tell a good
marriage by the number
of teeth marks on your tongue.
[ Laughter ]
>> From biting it.
[Laughter] Candor is
vastly overrated,
but I grew up in a
family of immigrants.
My grandparents are immigrants
from Russia and Poland.
I grew up in a town in
New Jersey, Bayonne,
New Jersey where [laughter]
everybody I knew had a grandmother
with an accent.
>> I did too, they just
had Southern accents.
>> That's good.
[Laughter] And I grew up-- Bayonne
was about 80 percent Catholic
and about 19 percent Jewish
which is what we were.
I thought Protestants were tiny
minority group, I-- some weird sect.
Imagine my surprise
when I went to Harvard.
[Laughter] All these names on their
building, Eliot, Weld, Winthrop,
so short, so crisp and they
ended in consonants, I--
but it left me with a lifelong
interest in immigration.
As Alison said, I did a book about
my own grandparent's immigration
to America and-- I
then started teaching--
and all through my writing career
I've written about immigrants,
but I started teaching at
George Washington University
and I started getting these stories
in a writing class of my students
from Ukraine and from
Vietnam and from El Salvador
who are living today the story my
grandparents had lived 100 years
ago, and that was really the
inspiration for the book.
Almost all of my writing over the
years has ruthlessly exploited my
family, and having used up all
of that material, I
turned to my students.
And in payment for exploiting
them, I actually dedicated the book
to my students [inaudible],
some of whom are here today
but that was really
the inspiration for it.
>> And you found that
they really are--
there are some things
that are very similar
to your grandparent's immigration
in the early 20th century
and some things that
are very different.
>> Well, my friend Jamie Morris
who just preceded me made the point
that historically, immigration
was a very lonely process.
When my grandfather left Bialystok
which is now in Eastern Poland,
he was out of touch with his own
sister for 50 years, 50 years.
There was no Skype, there was no
cell phone, there was no internet,
50 years she was behind
the iron curtain.
And the truth is today,
there are still things
about immigration that
never changed.
Every immigrant in the history of
the world leaves something behind.
They leave their graves
of their ancestors.
The air never smells
the same anywhere else.
The food never tastes
quite the same.
So this pain of separation is
common to every immigrant story
in the history of the world.
In the 13th century, a Persian
mystic named Rumi wrote something
called The Song of the Reed.
And he said when a reed is plucked
from a reed bed and you blow
through it, it makes a very
plaintive sound which is the sound
of the pain of separation
that the reed feels
from having been separated
from the reed bed.
An immigrant from Afghanistan
said to me,
"That's how I feel having
left out my-- Afghanistan.
I'm the reed who's been plucked
from the bed playing
that plaintive sound."
But in other ways, the
situation is very different.
I have a student who owes a--
brother married a woman from Brazil,
she was from Brazil and the woman's
family couldn't come to America
for the wedding so my student
in her bridesmaid's dress
and a digital camera and a
laptop went to the wedding,
took all these photographs,
put them up on the web
and the bride's family
back in a tiny village
in Brazil watched the
wedding in realtime on it--
surrounding a laptop
in their village.
My grandfather didn't
get to do that.
So, some things never change but
other things are very different.
>> And-- but you do still
have people leaving.
Your grandparents left essentially
because they were persecuted as Jews
in Eastern Europe and
you found a family
for whom a very similar story,
they weren't necessarily persecuted
but they certainly couldn't
fulfill their life's ambitions
in Ukraine as Jews.
>> This is actually a family whose
son was a student of mine, and Nick
and Sarah Stern [phonetic] grew
up as young Jews in the Ukraine
at a period when anti-Semitism had
actually gotten worse, not better.
Because Nick's mother was a doctor,
he couldn't aspire to be a doctor
because all Jews by edict
of Stalin had been prevented
from going to medical school.
So he became an engineer.
It was about the only
profession open to young Jews.
And so did Sarah, she
became an engineer as well.
They met in their first job.
And you know, immigration starts
with an active imagination.
It starts with a sense
of there is another life
out there for me, somewhere else.
>> And I said to the
Sterns, where did that spark
of imagination come from?
So Sarah said, well, we had a family
friend who had moved to Israel
and she wrote a letter
that my mother read to me
and the letter said, you
know, here in Israel,
we eat oranges the
way you eat potatoes.
And that orange became a
symbol of another life.
Then she said, I used
to watch Italian movies,
the Russians would never let in
American movies but they would let
in movies made by Italian communists
like Fellini and Carlo Ponti.
So she said, I would watch
these movies and I never listen
to the plot, I look
at the apartments.
[Laughter] Now my grandfather,
the sainted Avram Rogowsky,
when he came to America and
went back in the mid 60s,
he decided when he saw Russia that
the great chink in the Soviet armor,
what would pull down the entire
Soviet empire was plumbing.
>> He was right.
>> And that if Russians could see
American bathrooms, they would arise
as one and revolt against
the Russians.
[Laughter] Now of course
he was basically right.
>> He was basically right.
Yeah.
>> Of course.
He was a nut ball but he was right.
But the Stern story was similar, it
was the apartments, it was the way
of life that they saw on these
movies and then finally they decided
to immigrate and it
was very difficult.
>> But how would--
Sarah's apartment was like?
>> Well Sarah's apartment,
she lived in an apartment
where 28 people shared 1 bathroom,
28 people, and they were well off.
Her parents were professional
people.
So there were certain other impulses
to immigrate and they finally got
up their courage to immigrate but
at that time, it was a system,
the Soviets were just starting to
allow people to immigrate but they--
you had to get invited by
some relative from abroad.
The fiction was it was
family reunification.
So you had to have a
letter from cousin Morris
in Brooklyn saying I want
the Sterns to join me.
There actually didn't have
to be a cousin Morris,
but you had to get the
information to HIAS,
the Hebrew Immigration
Aid Society in Vienna
who could file a phony
application for you.
And you had to get
the information out.
But the Soviet censored
this information.
They wouldn't let it out.
So Nick was a pretty smart guy.
He wrote down on little
tiny pieces of paper all
of the vital information they
needed for the application
and he had Sarah sew the little
pieces of paper into the elastic
of his boxer shorts and
they would give the boxers--
every time a Jewish family left
Ukraine, they would give him a pair
of Nick's boxer shorts and say here,
bring the boxers to HIAS in Vienna,
tell them to look in the
elastic for our information.
It took them 20 tries.
As Nick says, you know,
there are a lot of guys
in Vienna walking around
in my underwear.
[Laughter] So they finally got out.
They breached the border
there, headed for Vienna,
they stopped for a coke
and Nick runs off the train
and he buys the first bottles
of warm Coca-Cola he's ever had
and he gives them to
his kids and I said,
"Nick, what did it taste like?"
He said, "Steve, it tasted like
freedom, tasted like freedom."
They get to America, it's
the worst day of his life.
Some of you have ever
been to Russia, you know,
the plumbing is such-- keeps
coming back to the plumbing.
The plumbing is such that the water
never rises in the toilet bowl,
you flush the bowl and
all the water goes out.
He said a Ramada Inn in Kennedy
Airport, his first night in America,
he flushes the toilet,
the water comes back up.
He says, oh my God,
I've broken the toilet.
[Laughter] They're gonna
send me back to Ukraine."
He spends the entire night
madly flushing the toilet,
he never gets the water down.
They finally get to Saint Louis
and he becomes a very
successful engineer.
Just to give you a sense of
where this family is today,
I interviewed them in
their penthouse apartment
on Central Park West, which
is only one of their houses
because they also have a condo
in Florida where, as Nick says,
Sarah's closet is bigger than
the apartment she grew up in.
>> So the American
dream still lives?
>> American dream still lives.
>> But, you know, you talk about
how we go through in this country
and we certainly have
seen it now these spasms
of anti-immigrants [inaudible].
And right now it's
mainly against Hispanics,
and you have a wonderful
Hispanic family.
>> What we're seeing is against--
>> You want to move the mic up--
>> -- two groups in America.
>> Can you move the microphone
up a little bit up here?
Up higher.
>> Is that a little better.
Okay. I'll hold like-- I'll hold it.
Look, there are-- there are
two groups in America today.
They're subject to tremendous
prejudice and persecution, Hispanics
and Muslims, we all know that.
I'm sorry to say having looked
at this issue for many centuries,
over many centuries as a historian,
this is a very American phenomenon.
Jamie Morris who was here just
before me talked about the Statue
of Liberty and we love to talk
about the Statue of Liberty,
love to tell the stories
about the nickels and dimes
that built the pedestal
and we get teary-eyed
about our own immigrant ancestors.
The fact is, however, throughout
our entire history as a country,
we have also had spasms
of anti-immigrant feeling,
and what is happening today
unfortunately is totally keeping
with American tradition.
In 1750s, 1750s, the group
that everybody was
attacking were the Germans,
1790s it was the French.
In the 1840s the Know Nothing Party
prospered as a political party
in this country by
attacking Irish Catholics.
In the 1880s, we passed
the Chinese Exclusion Act
to stop Chinese from
immigrating at all.
In the 1910s, there were--
Italians were considered non-white
in many parts of this country,
and in the 1920s, we hanged Sacco
and Vanzetti as much as
anything for their nationality
and their immigrant statuses
for their political views.
In the 1940s, we then turned 120,000
loyal Japanese-American citizens.
In my humble opinion, the
haters were wrong then
and they're wrong today.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering ]
>> And they're not just
wrong because of sentiment,
and they're not just wrong
because of some romantic notion
of our wonderful ancestors.
They're wrong on the
fact because the fact is
that immigrants give far more to
this country than they take away.
They contribute more.
[Applause] They contribute more
economically, they contribute
to our vitality, they contribute
to our entrepreneurship.
The day this book was published
last October, two Americans,
two Americans won the Nobel Prize
for Physics, one born in Canada,
one born in China, both of
them did their work in America.
One did the scientific work
that created fiber optics,
the other did the scientific work
that created digital photography.
Now you tell me how many
Americans are working in jobs today
because those two scientists
were welcome in America
and didn't do their
work somewhere else?
[Applause] So-- but if
you look at the history,
if you look at the
history, going back to 1750,
the language is exactly the same
because what the assumption is
that America is now perfect and
that the next we have to pull
up the drawbridge to stop the next
group, the Germans, the French,
the Irish, the Jews, the Italians,
the Japanese, the Chinese,
the next group is gonna corrupt our
culture and degrade our character,
profoundly misunderstands
the nature of America,
the genius of America is we're
never perfect, we're never perfect.
>> Striving for a more
perfect union.
That's right there.
>> And if the haters had their way,
most of us in this room would
be back in Bialystok in Poland
or wherever your family
is from as mine is.
And the story I tell
that illustrates--
this is about a Hispanic
man named Pablo Romero.
Pablo is born in a small
village in rural Mexico.
He had to drop out of school
when he was 10 years old.
There was no school left in
his village and in any case,
his parents needed the
money so he went to work
and his father brought him
to America as a farm worker
when he was 13 years old and
he worked in the lettuce fields
of Salinas, California for 7
years and then he was drafted
into the American army, it was the
best thing ever happened to him.
He went to Germany and he earned
his high school equivalency
and he really impressed
his commanders who said,
"I'm gonna come back looking
for you in Salinas, Romero.
And if I find you back in lettuce
fields, I'm gonna kick your butt
because you can do
something more than that."
He came back to America and
through the help of some--
of all things benevolent, government
bureaucrats helped him enroll
in a community college.
He went to school at night
every night while working
in the lettuce fields.
He went-- did go back to the lettuce
fields, went to community college,
then they kicked him out of the
library every night at midnight.
After 2 years he gets the
scholarship to UC Irvine.
He's studying at UC Irvine, still
hasn't been to high school and one
of his Hispanic professors
said to him, "Romero,
you should consider
going to medical school."
He said, "Medical school, I
haven't been to high school."
He said, "Romero, how many
Spanish-speaking doctors are there
in Salinas, California?"
The answer of course was zero.
>> He got-- he applies
to medical school.
Can't get the Case Western
in Cleveland by himself,
he had a trucking license so
he gets a trucking assignment
to drive a semi-trailer
to Cleveland.
Gotta be the only kid in the history
of Case Western Medical School
who drove to his interview
driving a semi-trailer.
[Laughter] They took him.
He decided not to go but he
did enroll at UCSF University
of California San Francisco
Medical School.
In his senior year,
he failed a test.
He was horrified.
He went to the-- went
to the professor
and said, "I knew this stuff."
And the guy said, "You people,
you people can't do the work
and your test proves it."
He is aghast.
He said, "Show me the test."
The guy shows him the test,
two pages had stuck together.
But because this professor
saw Pablo through the lens
of you people, he failed him.
When Pablo pointed out the problem,
the guys agreed to review the test,
put a big A on it, threw
the book at Pablo and said,
"Get the hell out of here."
He was so embarrassed.
Today, friends, Pablo Romero runs
a neighborhood medical clinic
in Salinas, California,
where 90 percent
of his clients are farm workers.
He today takes care of the
children and grandchildren
of the people he worked in the
fields next to all those years.
I do not know.
[Applause] I do not know a better
American than Pablo Romero.
[ Applause ]
>> So we have time
for a few questions.
The microphone is on-- at
the front of each isle,
if anybody has a question.
Do they wanna-- want to raise.
Steve, one of the things that you
found was the feminization of--
>> Yes.
>> -- of immigration.
>> This is a very interesting
phenomena.
As I said to Cokie, there are some
things that are very different
about modern immigration and one
of them is the feminization
of immigration.
A majority of immigrants
today are women.
Historically, this was not true.
But two very interesting
things have happened
to make this more and more possible.
First of all, it is far more
possible from a cultural
and social point of view to-- for
women to immigrate by themselves.
Historically, women needed men.
They needed a brother, a father,
an uncle to watch over them.
Today that's not true.
The second thing that's
happened is economic opportunity.
Historically, a lot of the jobs that
are open to immigrants were jobs
for muscle and for brawn.
Today, with the switch
to a service economy,
women in many ways are
more marketable than men.
My mom who just died a few
weeks ago in suburban hospital
in suburban Maryland, here, many
of you know it, every single person
who took care of my mother in that
hospital was a foreign-born woman
of color, every single one.
And if you took those women from
Jamaica and Trinidad and Rwanda
and the Cameroons out of
suburban hospital or any hospital
in Washington today, it
would collapse overnight.
>> Surely.
[ Applause ]
>> So thank you very much.
You guys are communicators
for a living
and you obviously have some
pretty powerful building pulpits
if you will.
So, how do we move the
titanic away from the iceberg?
How do we-- we keep telling
these stories of great immigrants
that are doing great things here and
yet we still have this hate which,
you know, we live-- we have freedom
of speech so we have this kind
of challenge going on, but there
are boundaries, you don't get to--
you all fire in a crowded theatre.
So, how do we collectively do this?
>> Good question.
>> Well, look as I said to
you, I don't know how many
of you heard the question
but he asked about the fact
that today there still
is this tremendous sense
of animosity toward immigrants.
Look, as I said to you,
there's nothing new about this.
We have to understand that there's--
we've gone through this
for several reasons.
First of all, there is
this impulse to xenophobia
in our country, it's
very deeply inbred.
Secondly, it's worse in
times of economic stress
because then people say, well,
foreigners are taking our job.
It is not true, foreigners
are not taking our jobs,
foreigners are creating new jobs.
But it is an easy thing to say.
All I can do is say-- to try to
tell these stories, I'm not a pol--
writing-- I haven't
written a political book,
I've written a book of stories.
It's just stories, but I hope people
will understand the contributions
Americans are making
everyday to our well-being,
and that's all I think we can do but
I think it's a useful thing to do.
>> But the other thing
that does happen
that you've certainly seen
is intermarriage, you know.
And the people who were once the
other are now your son-in-law and,
you know, and that
tends to change things.
>> Very much so.
The moment of greatest stress
in many immigrant families is
when their children get married, and
particularly their girl children,
because that's when
they define who they are
and who their parent's
grandchildren are going to be.
But as Cokie said, in many ways,
those moments bring us more
together than separate us.
>> So you have a question over here?
>> Yeah, you guys-- you
guys started off talking
about a little advice for marriage.
And Cokie, you've had a
distinguished career and I'd
like to ask you both
how has having your--
the career where you have so many
responsibilities, so many challenges
and you've really climbed
up that ladder,
how does that strengthen
your marriage
and what are some advice
you might have
for some newlyweds
facing those things?
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Well, you can start
by buying our book.
>> Go for it.
[ Laughter ]
>> It's for sale, we
just signed a couple.
Go ahead, girl.
>> No, no, no, you go.
I'm dying to hear.
[ Laughter ]
>> Everybody needs an editor.
I just married mine
and brought her along.
But I really think that the, you
know, Cokie is Catholic, I'm Jewish
and so we have our specialty, your
interfaith marriages and I think--
but look, I came to believe that
all marriages are mixed marriages.
Let's start with the marriage
between a man and a woman.
Anybody who has been
married more than--
anybody who has been married
more than two weeks knows
that gender is far more
a significant difference
than ethnicity or religion.
And even same sex couples, the
fact is the same issues arise,
issues of tolerance, issues
of mutual respect and issues
of taking pride and justice in
accomplishments, and one of the--
our greatest accomplishments we take
pride in are our six grandchildren
and it's a particular pleasure
to have a 9-year-old grandchild
sitting here and listening to us
and the faint hope that
someday she'll grow up
and actually remember who we were.
[Laughter] Yeah?
>> Could you comment briefly
about the success of Vietnamese
in the United States and also--
>> The success of what?
I didn't--
>> Vietnamese.
And also just a comment that the
congressional seat formerly held
by Cokie's parents is now held
by a Vietnamese republican.
>> That's true.
The Vietnamese are a great
success story in this country.
Few people are more hard working
and few people struggle
more to get here.
The fam-- the Vietnamese family
in my book tried to escape
from Vietnam sit-- you know, a
dozen times and he finally escaped.
They were floating
free on the open sea.
The engine had conked out in their
boat and the mother [inaudible]
and the family said to me
to save my two children.
The next thing I was going to
do was have to slit my wrist
and feed my children my blood.
Now, it didn't come to that
because they saw land the next day.
But in that period, in Southeast
Asia, if you washed up on the shore
of Cambodia, you'd be killed.
And if you washed up on the
shore of Thailand you'd be safe.
And you could imagine the moment
when my student's father stood
in the [inaudible] with that
boat and called out where are we?
Literally it was a life
and death question.
Fortunately, it was Thailand
and then eventually the
family found sanctuary
in the Philippines before
they came to America.
And that child, my student
was born in the refugee camp
in the Philippines and
her name today is Thai Phi
for the two countries, Thailand
and the Philippines
that gave her sanctuary.
Her family is not unusual,
the struggle and the tenacity
and the courage that her family
showed to escape from Vietnam
and survive that hardship
is just one tiny chapter
of this marvelous story that
immigrants are writing everyday.
>> Thanks.
>> We're getting the sign saying
over time, so we're gonna have
to say thank you and goodbye but--
it's been very, very
nice to be with you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks a lot.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.